I love Indiana Jones you all know that I
just really really like Indiana Jones a
lot
I even have a bullwhip well so a lot of
you enjoyed my collaboration review of
the matrix so I decided I'm going to do
other collaboration reviews for other
classic films and I'm always going to
try to get a big YouTube or somebody new
that I think is really cool to help me
out as you guys probably know I'm a huge
Indiana Jones fan I grew up with the
films I've loved them for a very long
time they've inspired me a lot I've even
made some of my own short films of
Indiana Jones as well I'm also a huge
fan of the smells know and they were
kind enough to agree to help me out in
doing a review of all for Indiana Jones
movies so let's get started all right
thank you very much Chris Stockman for
inviting us to do this review of
probably some of the best free movies of
all time that of course we're talking
about Indiana Jones
that's right Indiana Jones starring
Harrison Ford as the greatest
swashbuckling archaeologist that ever
lived the brainchild of Steven Spielberg
and George Lucas back when they were
young bucks and they they still have a
desire to make good movies yeah back
when George Lucas still had his brain
cells uh so all right let's be positive
here let's talk about Raiders of the
Lost are some of them are heroes
some of the not enemies and a big
turning rate is in the lost art was like
an explosion I mean it just like blew up
in people's minds there's like this
thing people are like oh my word like
adventure cereals again you see
adventure cereals were like these little
things in the 40s that were like these
short little 10 to 15-minute episodes of
something like Flash Gordon or something
where somebody had to escape a train or
climb onto a buggy from a horse or
something which was reenacted in Raiders
and Raiders took those very seriously
decided to make a huge movie out of it
became one of the most famous action
films of all time and it helped Harrison
Ford get out of the Star Wars thing it
helped him to become something other
than Han Solo so good 1981 it came out
and you get to meet Indiana Jones of the
Paramount logo fades into the mountain
you CNN atones for the first time and
you get to you meet the whip pretty
quick there's so many iconic things
going on in this movie from again like
you said the Paramount Rock the back
turn then we meet Indiana Jones the
width when he walks into the bar and you
see the big shadow you know which I mean
like there's all these great moments in
this movie but it's the pure definition
of an adventure film
that's right Indiana Jones is an
archaeologist who goes after religious
artifacts he likes to track down maybe -
maybe on Tuesday were going after a
little fat Golden Buddha and then maybe
this weekend we'll go after something
that was mentioned in the Bible in
Raiders of the Lost Ark we're referring
to the Lost Ark of the Covenant the
original tablets that had the Ten
Commandments as God told to Moses or I
read about at one time in Sunday school
they are all leaders of the lost
Spielberg directed that movie perfectly
I mean it's just it's as close to
perfect as you can get the score for the
film is one of the most memorable scores
of all time I mean you can just find
yourself you hear it it's like you
automatically to start kind of like
humming it and stuff I grew up seeing
Raiders and it was always kind of fun
for me but I remember I didn't watch it
for a long time until I was in my later
teens and I remember I decided to see it
again for some reason and I remember the
first time I noticed truly what it is
how great of a movie it is and how it's
not just a fun childhood film that I
grew up with and I remember sitting
there thinking gee these movies are made
well and and it made me automatically
want to start making my own the film's
truck chase sequence contains some of
the best stunt work I've ever seen in my
life and it's one of my favorite movie
scenes of all time this time where he
goes underneath the truck gets dragged
comes back up and then just kicks the
guy in the face
it's one of the most exhilarating scenes
I've ever seen because it's real it's
not fake there's no CGI it's a real guy
under there doing that stuff and that is
why the film is so exhilarating because
it was so hardcore and the way they
filmed it and you know these movies are
great too because even the secondary
characters that are worth noting on
great actors Alfred Molina I mean come
on uh Denholm Elliott as Marcus Marcus
Brody is such a fun little kind of um he
was bad back when you still had good
sidekicks that were funny more an
annoying Kinley's in this for God's
sakes
Gimli from Lord of the Rings is in this
movie as well there's a date eating
monkey in it for a little while that
dates so uh thank you so of course we're
talking about was Gimli um and you know
and Marion Karen Al and back when she
was hot and she was you know it's that
the chemistry between Indiana and and
what's-her-face woman Mary yeah I got I
mean it's like Oh actually that's why
Mary doesn't like it is because Indy
hooked up with it is like I
what's-her-face I'm going off after
something else yeah we're at this and
this is years after he had Willie so he
found her again it would always be fun
trust me
Raiders of the Lost Ark
the thing that was so cool about these
movies this one in particular was that
it had that supernatural element to it
and it didn't feel weird it didn't feel
out of place it all worked it was a
brilliant movie yeah and it takes place
in the late 30s and as well know who is
hanging around earth in the late 30s not
see us crazy shamans I hate these guys
and luckily the Ark of the Covenant hits
Nazis too and if you haven't seen the
movie then I don't know what to tell you
but close your eyes I'll melt your face
I'll melt your face Raiders of the Lost
Ark is arguably the best Indiana Jones
movie of I four you can have your own
personal opinions on but it is a great
movie and it's maybe one of the best
ways to kick off a franchise I've ever
seen that's the thing it's my favorite
film because again there are other
people who are bigger fans of the other
some of the other ones but this one
introduce you to Indiana it made you
want to continue on to the other ones
I'm going to go ahead and give this one
five out of five shows people always
give me crap for not giving anything
five out of five smooth well guess what
kids
rigs of the Lost Ark 5 out of 5 snows
if adventure has a name
it must be Indiana Jones a lot of people
are very split over this movie and
mainly because it was such a departure
from the tone of the first film and it's
very dark and has a lot of content that
parents were very offended by because
they took their kids to see it you know
God gets his heart ripped out and it
actually is the movie that helped launch
the modern-day pg-13 rating because back
then it was just PG or R and that's why
you got films like jaws being PG which
obviously today would never be PG
Spielberg actually suggested after
Temple of Doom a pg-13 rating and that's
how it actually got invented and it's a
completely different shift in tone from
the first movie and obviously that's why
I love it I love the fact they didn't
repeat themselves they didn't do
anything like they did in the first film
the action is the same kind of hardcore
stunt work and there's a lot more - than
in Raiders no time for love thought the
Jones all right this is a prequel to
Raiders of the Lost Ark Temple of Doom
of course not lot of people know that
and I gotta be honest I didn't know that
until about five minutes ago really no
didn't understand elects Edwin his Lost
Ark that he had Willie first that was
actually when I learned it ah see horse
stuff here in renews yeah it was a
pretty cool of course he had gone
through all the stuff with Marion yet so
this is about Indy he gets himself
caught up in some nonsense with data
from The Goonies and Steven Spielberg's
wife and they they have to fly to India
to find the sacred stones and fight mola
ROM it's not as exciting out of premises
Raiders of the Lost Ark because
everybody who you know you're familiar
with the the the Ten Commandments in the
Ark of the Covenant not as many people
are well versed in three magical
potatoes that are going to say one small
village but it you know it's he ends up
rescuing a lot of kids who are enslaved
feel good movie and the beginning of
Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom is
probably my favorite part because you
see Indiana Jones this is Harrison Ford
in 1984 man they're in a bigger movie
star arguably ever he's got these got
the white suit on he's rocket he's a
club obi-wan having drinks it's it's a
great way to kick off the second film
they did something completely different
and I actually love Temple of Doom and I
feel like it's very underrated mullah
Ron believe it or not is actually my
favorite villain there's Belloc is cool
the guy from Chris AC the guy said the
guy from crusade you know I mean that's
what I mean mullah ROM I just I relish
that just he's so funny and he's just
like he's so evil and he laughs and he
likes to pet a little mask that he wears
I mean I just find that so entertaining
basically the last half of this movie is
literally non-stop action and it never
stops
temple dome is a great ride I feel it's
really underrated I might actually even
like it a little more the Raiders I know
that's like blasphemy for some people
but I love both I love the darkness I
love the fact that they got graphic and
I love that I'm able to remember that
movie and abled that that gives me the
chance to say motor Dom pseudo Dom
bholaraam pseudo Rama
you betrayed Sheba prepared to die and
gives me a chance to do this India value
that's ridiculous shoving short rounds
in this and I get there's so much cool
stuff going on there's that cold chasing
you know when they're in the other into
the underground underground they're
tunneling delaying the mine scene yes
now look some people might say that
there's a little bit of jumping the
shark going on in this movie and I say
why because there's a voodoo doll in it
maybe never heard the Brady Bunch
maybe a jump the alligator a little bit
but you know and the bridge scene at the
end when they cut the bridge they hang
on this is a really really good movie
any other franchise this would probably
be the best film in the franchise this
video Jones I can't give it my best I'm
gonna Schmo it yeah and I'm gonna give
this movie four out of five shows yeah
I'm gonna go push I'll say four out of
five Stroh's um that scene at the end of
the bridge is amazing it just shows how
ballsy Indiana Jones I mean there's some
silly shit going on in this movie though
too and there fly the the raft from the
plane and the mountains but you have fun
with it that's the thing is the fact
that the atonement is consistent and it
was a nice part too but it led us to
something even greater and it really
scares me about trying new food because
anytime I go to restaurant I've never
been there before I'm worried they're
gonna serve snake surprise
so now on to the Last Crusade Indiana
Jones is on the quest of a lifetime the
Last Crusade is actually my favorite of
the trilogy I love the fact that it was
able to take a hero that was so hardcore
and you didn't really know that much
about his past you just knew little
slivers of things and it really delves
into Indiana Jones's past because the
first scene is with a young River
Phoenix it's it's young Indiana Jones
and then later on the movie you meet
Sean Connery who just made that movie so
incredible so you really get a feel for
Indiana Jones as a person not just as an
action hero and it made him a lot more
vulnerable which was something that was
so important to the Indiana Jones series
was his vulnerability as a hero he
wasn't the kind of guy like Rambo who
comes in mows everyone down and then
walks out fine he gets his butt kicked
in like every movie endlessly just by
like a little chance he wins at the end
and that's just how he always kind of
scraped by on being a dirty fighter and
everything and that's why he was so
relatable because he was like a human he
was like just a normal guy you really
cared for when you warned him to get out
of these situations now we're here to
review the Last Crusade Jeremy Jones is
joining us yeah I had to stop in for the
last crusade because it's the Last
Crusade
it's his favorite Indiana Jones movies
my favorite Indiana Jones movie maybe
it's not is his Raiders of the Lost Ark
but we had Jeremy for this one because
in Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade to
get three generations of Jones's good to
see young Indy with River Phoenix get to
see Harrison Ford obviously and Sean
Connery as Indies dad that's one of the
reasons it's my favorite it's Indies dad
and it's Sean Connery it's like when
when when stuff going away the changes
my life plan is in these days yes not
better than that yeah
you know why I really enjoy this movie
though too is because a lot of times
especially with comp adept throat comedy
in there and just doesn't work the
comedy just flops this comedy works the
whole way through it's consistent with
the adventure that's going on and the
jokes are fun and it's a it's the tone
is fantastic in this exam and it shows
in Dee's backstory why is afraid of
snakes how we gonna swim how he got his
scar the Harrison Ford actually has you
know and he's really back stories you
like it'll either work or a wow this one
absolutely worked I thought it was great
but for some adventures one Joe's is not
enough jr. don't call me that please
Last Crusade has all the great action
it's hilarious actually it's probably
the funniest one and the final scene in
this film where he does the three
challenges is the most intense scene for
me anyway in all the Indiana Jones films
because there's just something so
suspenseful about having to go through
these various challenges that he goes
through it's all handled so well
I love Last Crusade it's my favorite of
the three the original Indiana Jones
trilogy in my opinion is like the Star
Wars trilogy the original it's just like
a great classic piece of filmmaking and
if you're a film fan you have to see it
you call the shop eulogy and since I
showed us the back story and they're
going for the cup of eternal life the
Holy Grail it's a great way to end the
Indiana Jones franchise and just bring
backs the shamans bring back then Jeremy
look at that guy Ronnie aren't gonna
come at man up yeah but it's it's
incredible that like again you need the
Nazis to be back there back in this it
works there's that crazy scene with Indy
bumping into Hitler I mean there's oh
yeah that freaks me out I was like oh I
didn't notice it when I first saw it
when I was a kid oh wait a minute is
that the guy and yeah have any signs and
I'm like eight all my other side the
diary just that's the guy from The
History Channel that to me is the type
of humor I'm talking about yeah you
watch it it's silly but it's so fine and
it works and it's great I need to see
that it's humor that just freaked me out
of money you signed your face-to-face
yeah you don't think that like when he
played nips on it but he's got the diary
and it's like oh no he's found about
this asshole long so I feel like man I
go it's comedy it's action is suspense
and it's my favorite artifact that he
went after me you talk about the the cup
that gives eternal life and we cannot
let the Nazis if their hands off this
thing up and there's a there's a what an
800 year old night guard again that's my
favorite part but if he gets to the back
room of the nose pray it's like do you
know there's some porn bags let's uh
balled up tissues Direct TV and I'll get
the action scene that led up to what the
tanks was awesome he's there and he has
to go on
he has trials to go through he has to go
through the 300
gosh dude and then in the cup it thinks
gonna be this glamorous thing and it's
this little piece of clutter
those people are trying to kill my dad
it's a new experience for me
happens to me all the time Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade that is my
favorite credit rolling sea of all time
is when you got the form yeah so uh
Marcus Indies dad in India all riding
off into the sunset through the whole
credits it it pisses me off when you see
this movie on TNT and they do that
credit you know I think in the end I
want to enjoy the great John Williams
score just watch these guys ride off
into the Sun sank you find out Indies
name yeah real man
we're name the dog bring up a new drone
screwed up the best well it's so much
smaller Christian I'm gonna go 4.5 out
of 5 shrubs I love this movie it's great
I like Raiders just a little bit better
mr. John Doe for me I can do actor - I
can't Schmo it up but I will say that
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade is
awesome tacular I'm going to actually
give this movie four point nine out of
five smoke I think Raiders is the better
million as much as announcements Raiders
is the better movie but I like your safe
I'm not a problem with crusade is that
there's some senseless death in the
middle of it that makes no sense you
know those guys that are protecting the
conflict they've been over time to get
you nine of them died this boat chase
scene and nobody's upset about Ronnie
there's no reason for it to because they
could all been friends that they had a
conversation
guys like oh no your hands being held in
this castle good luck on your glasses so
you can't a to my guy yeah all right so
brave movie love it
I stuck around for my favorite one I I
didn't I didn't walk out of the movie
Crystal Skull when I watched it but I
will walk out of the run of the
Fairweather friend when times are good
we're talking last crew stays on board
I'm out peace
a lot of people hate this movie a lot of
people hate it a lot of people really
like it not too many people love it I'm
somewhere in the middle I find a lot of
enjoyment in the film I really do I
think there's a lot of good things to be
found in it I know I know Christian I'm
not sure about mark I know Christian
does not like this movie okay so we are
reviewing Rocky 5 uh oh sorry I
apologize the same thing it's I think
it's called Indiana Jones in the Crystal
Skull it is the birth of the Crystal
Skull Christian it's not as bad as Rocky
5 because Rocky 5 never existed this
movie existed and it wasn't nearly as
good as the first three I'm still pretty
convinced that this is a Saturday Night
Live sketch I don't think it's a real
movie the Indiana Jones I knew would
never jump into a refrigerator or a
truck with two Russians ago damn that's
farther than I thought or whatever the
hell he says and he said it's a and the
Russians would watch that scene in the
trailer when when he jumps into the
Russians the whole time he's having this
monologue for themselves the Russians
are going like this well what are we
doing anything there's a sense they're
starstruck their meeting Harrison Ford
is retarded
damn I thought that was closer there are
things I like about the film I think the
action scenes are all done really well
yes there aren't really over-the-top
elements like nuking the fridge and the
monkey swinging and everything but
honestly I don't understand why so many
people bring attention to that because
every Indiana Jones movie has an
incredibly over-the-top moment I mean
look at Temple of Doom
indeed jumps out of a plane with three
people with a raft that inflates in
mid-fall lands on a mountainside with
the raft slides all the way down the
mountain what falls off that mountain
into a ravine goes through the rapids
and then eventually survives I find that
pretty over-the-top we kind of buy into
it because I don't know it's from the
80s or whatever and we just sort of
accepted that's really all Indiana Jones
is the seer it's a serial thing where a
guy continues to survive something that
obviously no one would ever be able to
survive I guess I just don't really care
that much about it
Harrison Ford couldn't care less that he
is playing Indiana Jones movie he is
literally acting he's like well I guess
I'm Indy write him and totally like go
for looking at me as a little fridge I
disagree with that point because I think
Harrison Ford is good as an old Indiana
Jones I don't think he's just going
through the motions I think he put a lot
of effort into playing Indy and I think
the Shia LaBeouf character I like a
younger kind of underling was I making
fun of you when you were going on your
ran I mean it's not a good movie there's
a lot about elements of it but I like a
lot of things too I like seeing what
happened in Indy I like that there's a
young guy coming up to have to be Shia
LaBeouf just go play with it it has to
be mutt okay did it have the kids name
have to be mutt no I could've been
anybody can be Ryan Gosling it could
have been anyone feeling stupid Zinj
mutt it's ridiculous
come on gene
I find Harrison Ford great in the film I
think he was fantastic with his stunt
work still I like Shia LaBeouf in the
movie I don't really like the addition
of John Hurt's character and I feel like
even though Marion's character is really
nice to see her back I don't know if she
fits in the movie but here's my main
problem with Indiana Jones for the first
three movies Indy was always so
vulnerable and he was getting his butt
kicked all the time every fight he
always just almost barely wins it's
really exhilarating to see him come back
at the end like in every film there's
always a scene like that in Indiana
Jones for Indy is always on top of
things his life is never really in much
danger throughout all of Indiana Jones
for when he fights the big Russian it's
pretty much an even fight you know the
scene with the ants he's never really in
trouble with the ants the jungle chase
scene he's pretty much on top of things
the entire time he never really gets his
butt kicked in the movie and so it lost
a lot of the tension that the first
three films had a lot of that
white-knuckle fear for Indies life is
not in the fourth film and that's my
biggest problem with the movie he's
always on top of things so a lot of the
suspense is gone but I still enjoy the
film it's my least favorite for sure but
I still enjoy certain aspects of it and
I feel like there are a lot of things
about it are very underrated I don't
mind the Crystal Skull element because
it's actually true like there are these
crystal skulls and look for us I have me
I was very interested in this joint Oh
wonder how they're going to do this this
is really cool and then you get Shia
LeBoeuf flying around again from trees
with CGI monkeys Nazis and CGI ants all
over the place an 87 year old karenallen
like turning into dust like one of the
creatures in the first movie it's it's
unbelievable like you could literally
see any editor of looking at Karen Ellen
and going how are you still alive okay
look you wanted Indy to end up with
Marion right out of the three so I get
on it with a Nazi girlfriend from Last
Crusade you're gonna end up with Kate
Capshaw
she's taken by the director so he's
going to end up with Karen Allen I like
I'm sorry women don't age that well
after they hit 90 Christian I really am
Benjamin Button they could have done
something um but I don't know but
that again there's so many problems to
the movie the tone is a mess George
Lucas ruining this movie and let
Spielberg take a dive that should have
kept Frank Darabont's screenplay it's
horrible I hate this movie it's one
point five out of five snows so you
liked it
things like are you gonna be in a bad
mood like this for the rest of the day
I'll be in a we also have to talk about
the other three Indiana Jones movies
that are pretty good I will be on worst
mood if they actually do five width
LaBute and if you start screaming
optimist in the middle of it I'm out I
think he's going to attend his
contractor Larry moving I'm going to
give crystal skulls two point one out of
five schmoes it's it was great to see
any back on screen I thought Harrison
Ford was fun to watch and it's just the
movie itself just just didn't hold up I
hate it no I don't think I cover my ears
why were you
so I'm sure you guys a burnished Mouse
but if you haven't go check out their
channel because their videos are very
good and very entertaining to do a lot
of collabs they're very into the YouTube
community you should check them out
thanks a lot Chris we enjoy doing this -
the fourth part but um thank you very
much and thank you to Jimmy Jones and by
the way maybe crystal skulls is the
fifth best Indiana Jones funder still
skulls and by the way maybe crystal
skulls is the fifth best Indiana Jones
film because Chris upman made Indiana
Jones movie that ain't half bad
that's better than the fourth one I'll
tell you that anything is it's not that
the crystal skulls what I called the
crystal skulls maybe that's what the
name of it is called the Crystal Skull
there's a bunch of them right I wasn't
insulting Chris's movie by the way it's
a good movie he's just in a bad mood
anymore crystals going anything but they
just say you know of course for
something whose is better it's gonna be
okay it's gonna be okay apologize hey
hey hey who wants to go see Inception
huh me yeah there you go I appreciate
that so as you guys know I love you
Hannah Jones thanks a lot for watching
this video I'm going to do more
collaborations but I thought I'd leave
you guys with a little tiny preview of
some of the work I've done in my Indiana
Jones films so you can kind of get a
feel for just how much I love it these
are some highlights from the two films
that I've made thanks for watching guys
if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
man eyes don't forget to subscribe to
this mouth
you